okay so you got Alvin Bragg we just
played Leticia James this is what
they're saying they're going to do as
candidates this is these are powerful
positions is this prosecutorial
misconduct and select a prosecution 100
as a former State prosecutor what Alvin
Bragg is and as a former Attorney
General what Leticia James is it is 100
Sean when you're a prosecutor of any
kind if there's an appearance of a
conflict you get off the case your
office gets off the case here it it
isn't even an appearance it is an
inherent conflict and they're touting it
they're proud of it not even 90 days ago
when she was sworn in again she talked
about before she talked about protecting
New Yorkers from crime from rapist from
anything she talked about going after
Donald Trump not by name but she talked
about going after him well she said one
other thing she actually wants the
punishment to be not only it's a civil
case by the way it's not a criminal case
but that he could never ever practice
business again in the state of New York
that's what she's seeking is this
selective prosecution and is this
prosecutorial misconduct if you run to
go after one human being if I have one
goal in the next years of my life it's
to get all the bar associations to make
it unethical conduct for any prosecutor
to run for office on the campaign pledge
to get somebody you know the title of my
book I didn't make it up yet Trump it's
her campaign promise get Trump that
where it came from it came exactly from
her it's her campaign promise I borrowed
it I probably owe her royalties
because that's what she promised and no
prosecutor should be allowed to
prosecute the first motion I would make
if I were Trump's lawyer get her off the
case get bragged off the case
I don't believe in New York now when
when Pam Bondi was the Attorney General
of Florida for two terms you did a
phenomenal job I I interviewed you
during that time many times
um I do not believe Donald Trump can get
a fair trial in New York state never
mind New York City Am I Wrong well and
you know the whole country knows about
this case they know about this Witch
Hunt but what's different here is she
ran on the promise Alvin Bragg ran on
the promise especially here in Manhattan
of going after Donald Trump he was
elected on that promise and that's the
jury pool right here who the jury's
going to be the jurors are going to be
people who voted for brag and want to
help him make and fulfill his campaign
promise our only hope is of the large
crowd we have here they are the only
normal New York people I'd love them
[Applause]
there are problems with judges in New
York too do you think any judge wants to
be what they call dershowitz people are
going to look at them and say oh my God
that's the judge that freed Donald Trump
what they did to me when I defended him
is nothing compared to what they would
do to a judge
totally ostracizing no judge attacked
with lies which you're going to sue a
lot of people right yeah but you know
it's cost me a lot of money and a lot of
time to defend myself all of it is the
result of doing what John Adams did 200
years ago defending somebody who was
very unpopular that's what American
lawyers have to do okay I believe this
is a tsunami of legal
issues that they're putting on Trump why
are they doing it because Democrats will
say no we think Donald Trump's the
easiest to beat on the other hand it
seems like they're preventing him from
running a campaign and most of them seem
to want him in an orange jumpsuit so I
would imagine they want to take him down
period end of sentence Am I Wrong of
course they do this is a one-two punch
by James and by Bragg and they're going
to be more you got do you got Georgia
you got a special counsel and you have
prosecutors you know prosecutors not
people like you they not only can make
Witnesses sing they can get them to
compose and to create new lyrics and to
make up stories well the lawsuit 500
million dollars that Trump uh is now
suing Michael comb will that be
successful does that have a good chance
of success you know I I Sean I don't
know I'm glad he's doing it because he
has to he's standing up for himself
against these women
privilege well it's out the window now
right it's out the window professor and
I were just talking about that
attorney-client privilege has been
thrown out the window because of Donald
Trump all my clients I have to give them
a random warnings what you tell me May
no longer be secure because of what
these judges are now serious I'm serious
I have to give that warning to my
clients now all right Alan dershowitz
Pam Bondi hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else